y los ojos de prime se llenan de
lágrimas cuando recuerda como las
manifestaciones pacíficas que llevaron a
miles de jóvenes nigerianos a salir a
las calles para protestar contra la
brutalidad policial se tornaron
extremadamente violentas con al menos 56
muertos
este lugar era una zona de guerra pero
era más el ejército luchando contra
civiles civiles desarmados civiles
pacíficos civiles que ejercían su
derecho constitucional
el 8 de octubre comenzó la ola de
manifestaciones en todo el país
lideradas por jóvenes impulsadas a
través de las redes sociales el motivo
de su rabia la violencia sistemática de
la unidad de la policía a sharp por sus
siglas en inglés escuadrón especial
antirrobo ahora disuelto pero también
para exigir el cese de la brutalidad
policial contra la población el martes
un panel judicial independiente comenzó
con las audiencias en lagos para
investigar los reclamos contra el zar
una de las demandas de los manifestantes
en el caso de que no consigamos justicia
entraremos a ver al mundo que este panel
está siendo parcializado pero por ahora
estamos estudiando el progreso de los
procedimientos del panel y creemos que
vamos a conseguir justicia para ellos
a partir del 20 de octubre las protestas
fueron reprimidas por las fuerzas de
seguridad con disparos y agresiones
contra los congregados la conmoción de
los asesinatos en las marchas ha dejado
el movimiento de protesta tambaleándose
con los activistas temiendo
persecuciones pero la ira de una
generación frustrada por la mala
gobernanza está hirviendo en el país más
poblado de áfrica y vislumbra nuevas
manifestaciones